mentioned Patrice yeah he's one of the
greats what was he like as a person he
was everything if he was being cool he
was the coolest guy he ever met if he
was being funny he was the funniest guy
you ever met he was being an [ __ ] he
wanted to [ __ ] kill him I still have
arguments with him like that's how like
the level of this guy he's been dead for
like [ __ ]
11 coming up in 11 years I can't believe
it you know I had all kinds of uh you
know amazing conversations just talking
about life how we ended up where we were
at how the two of us ended up being
friends
you know I'd Fallen outs with them I
just I had like everything I mean good
times bad times had to like [ __ ] take
breaks from each other I mean we used to
take breaks from white people in general
and like I had to take breaks from going
down to The Cellar sometimes it's like I
just want to go down there and just
[ __ ]
have to have all my deflector Shields up
and I just you know
Miss
besides them like like man what would
they be saying about this you know